central park was developed in the
mid-19th century as the rapidly
expanding city grew north up through
manhattan
but building this much-needed open space
meant the forced removal of a small but
thriving village of mainly black new
yorkers
and it's called seneca village and it
was located right about here on the
western part of central park between
what is now 82nd and 89th street
founded by african americans at its peak
it had about 300 residents all of whom
were escaping racial violence that was
happening just a few kilometers to the
south and so you've got all these little
homes sort of dotting the landscape of
seneca village long forgotten by most
new yorkers uncovering the story of
seneca village has been largely down to
decades of work by historian cynthia
copeland
it was a really thriving community at
one point the community had the three
churches the cemeteries two cemeteries
it had a school
newspapers at the time which were
heavily in favor of building central
park described the area as occupied by
miserable broken down looking shanties
but as copeland and her team uncovered
more about the people who lived there a
different story emerged
andrew williams was the
one of the first property owners in
seneca village some of andrew williams
neighbors include the
mccullen families obadiah mccollum was a
was a chef and he lived in a two-story
framed house these are counter
narratives to some of the stories that
we saw in the newspapers
one of andrew williams descendants maria
williams says copeland's work has helped
change the narrative of her family's
history
for this
to come out
is
satisfying because it's healing an old
womb that was passed from generation to
generation
these days the story of the village is
enjoying unprecedented attention
it's even featured in a new exhibition
at the metropolitan museum of art an
institution situated fittingly just on
the other side of central park
gabriel zondo al jazeera new york